the 22-year rule of president ferdinand
marcus is seen today as a brutal and
divisive period in philippine history
a people power revolution forced him out
of office and into exile in 1986
but decades later his son ferdinand
marcus jr also known as bongbong is a
front-runner in this year's presidential
election my intention to run it may seem
surprising to many but the political
resurgence of the marcuses didn't happen
in an instant
experts say the marcuses have spent
years using social media to rewrite
history
online memes like this
new zealand prime minister jacinta adern
praising bonbon marcus jr
or of the american basketball superstar
michael jordan receiving a box of bread
from the late president have dominated
online chat groups
it's even said that the marcuses will
give away tons of gold bars and other
treasure if bongbong becomes president
treasure that fact checkers and
journalists say does not exist
but the story has already spread widely
on social media even after twitter
announced last week that it has
suspended hundreds of pro-marcus
accounts i think it's also important to
consider the desperation of
many poor filipinos
and that desperation economic and social
their needs
the pandemic has exacerbated that and
this is just demarco says exploiting
that desperation
making filipinos believe that there is a
quick way out of poverty al jazeera
requested an interview with mr marcus's
campaign team
there was no response
the marcus camp has repeatedly denied
owning social media troll farms
we know that social media has very low
verifiability the philippines once a
shining star on democracy in asia is now
called the backsliding country
the philippines is the biggest facebook
user in southeast asia and the sixth in
the world researchers say the higher
populations exposure to social media the
higher its vulnerability to
disinformation this information they say
has the power to obliterate the ability
of people to distinguish what is real
and what is not jemela allendogen al
jazeera manila